talking of your childhood and then your
production in in Cardiff we've got a few
lines of dialogue right yes between Luke
and Leia so I just wondered would you
like to have a go
maybe recreate we could do a Brin Anessa
nice big font nice big font there we go
okay okay so are you ready I'm always I
think you have some music music okay
Star Wars music okay okay now I'm sorry
Leia
I'm very late I know and I'll tell you
for why I look what's occurring well
what it is I've just been with my friend
c-3po c-3po that's it now tell me yes do
you know the force of course I know the
force what you take me for a fool you
see the force is very strong in my
family I have the force my brother
Trevor had the force God rest his soul
my sister has the force but here's the
thing you are my sister Leia I know
I've always known fair enough
so where do you go in now then I'm
heading off lair for a little chat with
Darth Vader and I'll tell you what that
guy is a shower of [ __ ] Luke that's no
way to talk about your father Darth
Vader's my father well blow me back off
Luke you had your chance you never took
it
sorry lair may the force be with you
tidy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you